don't you just love Christmas come on
man you don't actually believe in
Christmas dear another round of shots
please no not for me
typical yo what's your problem in man
you've abandoned me for some girl you
couldn't walk a mile in my shoes you
think my shoes are just easy to walk a
mile in you and your stupid hat Merry
Christmas
she only now
oh I'm you you're me
did we just Freaky Friday
dude it's Christmas Eve supposed to be
Sanders parents for dinner tonight now
you have to go Christmas doesn't exist I
don't know anything about it I'll help
you fine
do not mess this up drastic Zack relax I
got this might check hot yeah oh and
there's one tiny thing I forgot to
mention her dad is Santa Claus daddy
this is that hello mr. Claus introduce
me you've been having some problems with
your friend Zack told you that of course
you told me that you tell me everything
well what else have I told you finally
I'm late don't you dare kiss her
what's that mistletoe huh why are you
acting so weird
excuse me we got some reindeer illegally
parked outside Ryan Ryan what the hell
is Sandra's ex-boyfriend Ryan doing in
there
he's family spending the holidays in
Europe so we invited them hopefully
won't act is weird are you ryan loves
Europe why wouldn't you go with that oh
this Christmas drinks pretty hot
more like cats nuts roasting on an open
fire
and to all a good night with the ferry
Oh Santa's been kidnapped Johnston
Justin Zach I mean Justin Monica Oh
we have to save Santa we know where
Santa is the building is going to be
guarded why are you putting us in so
much danger over a stupid made-up
holiday is this really about Christmas
or you're just jealous of me and Sandra
unbelievable I'm sorry I found happiness
and you're still by yourself I thought
you were my best friend why don't you
just roll out of Justin
oh my god Santa with this do you Oh Oh
Ryan are you doing this whoever where is
the fat bastard's had at midnight on
Christmas Eve become Santa that's why
I'm doing and that's why I dated Santa
but I love her you do yeah man looks
like it's ho ho hos before Bros
you'll have to work together a great
friendship is something you have to
never forget that
believe in each other believe in
Christmas
it's too late Anna it's never too loose
sir
how'd you know him Zack he sees you when
you're sleeping you believe Holly
I'm me again I believe this belongs to
me Santa
what are we gonna do with Ryan you only
that little [ __ ] to me here comes Santa
Claus
but I have to go I have to pee no
absolutely not I'm not gonna have you
look at my no then what do you propose
don't even think about looking at it I'm
not looking God are you almost done give
away bigger blinder than I do